greetings from podcast Ville the church
is brought to you by post mates your
personal delivery service in this life
who can you count on who what how you're
gonna count who can you ask to bring you
a nice red wine at 4 p.m. sushi at 9
p.m. and a breakfast burrito at 8 a.m.
I'll tell you who you want to know who
bounce mates there you go it's your
personal delivery service whatever you
want whenever you want they'll bring it
to you nobody delivers like post mates
no more annoying trips to the store with
your sandals on your feet without cream
on them you don't even gotta go know
where the store is
post mates will deliver anything to you
anything download the app it's available
for iPhone or Android browse through the
local restaurants and businesses from
comfort of your couch now for a limited
time only post mates is given the church
family 100 hours of delivery credit for
your first 7 days free money to start
your free delivery download the app
right now and use promo code Joey Diaz
that's Joey Diaz for 100 hours of free
delivery service credits for your first
7 days when you download the post mates
app get anything you need anytime you
need download post mates and save the
code with no save with the code Joey
Diaz JOA y di AZ who's better than you
the show is brought all brought to you
by onyx calm listen for your health
needs on it is the answer whether you
need kettlebells shroom tech sports room
tech immune and it is the way to go I
popped a few offer brains this morning
and read a script who's better than me
nobody go down at that common pressing
Church and get 10% off your order
delivered tea house kick this
[ __ ] mealy so the purple tape
that what we were listening to is
actually a really old record it's um
back I graduated from college in 1990
and I had been singing with a friend of
mine named Liz Mitchell we had a group
called Liz and Lisa Perry popular on
campus at Brown University and it was
really fun but at a certain point after
college we decided to go our own
separate ways but in college I often
saying harmonies more than the lead I
wrote a lot of the songs but I was more
of the harmony singer and so I wanted to
make a recording of these songs a lot
you know that I had written
but with me singing the lead so I made
this acoustic record in the apartment up
on 52nd Street 52nd between 9th and 10th
with Juan Pitino who went on to produce
a couple of the other records I made but
I wanted to have something I also that I
could sell it shows so we used to make
cassette tapes so we did a run of these
acoustic tapes called the purple tape
and it had about 10 or 12 songs on it
that off that many of them later ended
up being on my other major label albums
but this is just an indie record that I
put out myself and that I would sell it
shows you know and years later like 20
years later my friend said you got to
put this you know you got to do
something with this tape you have to put
it out on CD so instead of just putting
it out on CD the way it was I felt like
I think I felt a little self-conscious
like it seemed like it was back from the
early 90s the font on the record the
photograph even the performance style
for me singing and playing it just it
felt like it was from a certain time era
I like to joke around that my hair I
didn't even have the same hair products
that I do now like we you know the hair
is like fluff it was very 1990s so I
wanted to contextualize it so next we
have something called 10x work it was
very 1980s you'd sneak into a club you'd
have 10 acts and you sleep in - it was
sneak into a club but so I decided
instead of just putting the record out
as a CD I decided to make it into more
of like a time capsule and my friend
Andy denna mark who's a great journalist
and radio person in New York I had him
interview me so we did a full CD where
we talked about each track and we put
the whole purple tape into context and
if you look at the purple tape CD
packaging which I you know if you buy a
CD if anybody buys a CD it's a big
booklet inside and it has all these
photographs from early New York City
when I was living there and different
friends playwrights and just different
people who were involved in my life back
then who sort of started out with me in
New York they wrote about the time
period and we talked about it on the on
this CD as well so it sort of put things
in context and then I rerecorded one of
the songs called snow day and then I
mean after that came out many years
later I put out some of those songs with
the band on my major label records so
for me it was just something I wanted to
do but
there were so many people who wanted to
hear it that I decided to put it out but
I definitely needed people to understand
this is not a new record this is an old
record and let me tell you about what
was going on during that time you know
it's uh whether it's musica comedy it's
a process and I never I knew your song
yeah I watched on MTV I thought you were
adorable and then while you were in that
thing I read something somewhere that
you were the first person to have a top
single and not b-side then you were
still like I just read this somewhere
yeah you were playing the guitar in the
train in New York or something that's a
very nice glamour of what is it like it
it was actually more traditional I I had
been playing music ever since I was a
kid all through college I did probably
do some busking for fun my friend and I
we would do busking or like in Boston or
wherever we were because it was fun to
play in front of people but I was
playing the club so I was playing the
bitter end right and I was playing the
Lonestar Roadhouse and the wetlands and
CBGB's and CD gallery and just a bunch
of the clubs I don't think I played at
the village game right way to the
village yeah yes I spent a lot of time I
lived down there for a while and yeah we
were just you know playing all the
different clubs either with my band or
acoustically and um or whatever
different versions so I'd been doing it
forever but I the song stay was recorded
in that same apartment on 52nd Street we
actually had gotten a demo deal from a
record label so there were some labels
kind of interested things were kind of
happening we were playing it you know
South by Southwest and this music
seminar called new music seminar where
we'd meet all the music industry people
and there was some good interest but we
weren't I wasn't getting signed yet but
so I recorded to stay with my band in
this apartment in New York City on 52nd
Street and ethan hawke was my neighbor
and and we were all so friendly we met
each other through some other actors
there was a guy named Josh Hamilton
who's an actor who I went to college
with and they had done the movie alive
together it was funny there was a ethan
hawke and his friends there were so many
guys we were hanging out with because
Ethan had done the movie Dead Poets
Society and they needed the movie alive
and that that was about it like a soccer
team of guys that crashes
in Colombia and Illeana Douglas is also
in it but like there was just these huge
groups of guy actors who are all friends
with each other and I got to meet all
these nice interesting cute guys and we
were all hanging out together in New
York actresses actors playwrights
musicians and just like the creative
gang you know and I'd write music for
Ethan's theater company but anyway so I
recorded the song with Juan and Ethan
was doing the movie reality bites and he
asked me for a copy of my song stay and
the song went onto the soundtrack of
reality but I mean there was also music
supervisors and people from the record
company and Ben Stiller was directing it
and he wanted to put the song on the
record and they came to see me at the
wetlands and it was like a whole thing
but they put the song in the movie and
this radio station in Houston started
playing it on the radio and it went and
everybody caught on it they it became a
sing-off with RCA records off the
soundtrack from reality bites and it
went to number one without me being
actually signed to a label for movies so
it's really it sounded it's it was
really exciting
I mean honestly there was a record label
RCA Records once they started playing it
on the radio there was I'm still
friendly with my radio promoter from
back then skip Bishop and he did all the
things that record companies do to
promote the record but it did go to
number one and it's given me so much
creative freedom because for the song to
go to number one and have that much
success without heavy record company
involvement on the creative side I think
that's given me confidence and also it
gives I think usually record company
people confidence in my vision you know
when it comes to making records well I
made a mind though when I read that I
know for a girl that's so she's got
balls just playing that yeah so when I
met you that's why I hugged you that
first song yeah i bided you think I gave
you a hug I'm like oh my god she's a
savage just like me
totally I know I look like a little stop
you know okay but I'm not you started
you your life in Dallas
I started yeah I grew up in Dallas I was
born in Bethesda Maryland my dad's a
doctor so we traveled around a lot when
he was doing all of his training and I'm
back when I was born he was doing us
like military up at the Naval Hospital
and Bethesda so I was born there but we
moved to California
but mostly I was raised in Texas that's
where my family's found a great place
it's a big place there's a lot of
different parts of Texas yes it's funny
actually when I went to college I found
out my roommate this gal that I sang
with for years Elizabeth Mitchell she
was from New York and I was from Texas
and she thought I was a small-town Texas
person because she had come to Texas
from New York on it like an exchange
program for a few weeks but stayed in
one of those really tiny towns where
everybody hangs out at the Dairy Queen
and she thought I was like from this
little tiny town but I was from Dallas
which is you know big metropolitan city
you know Dallas and um and I thought she
was from New York City cuz she was from
New York so she's the big city person
but she's actually from Westchester this
little tiny town with a little tiny Main
Street and like the drugstore everybody
goes to so it's kind of reversed she was
the small-town girl did you get the
breath what why no one when a 1986 I
started graduating miss Kennedy you just
miss yes mister my buddy graduated brown
lady - yes with Kennedy yes and he would
tell me how her story's not about like a
kid but when his mom would visit him how
what happened campus David people said
the woman's a yell horrendous things
yeah yeah you - I didn't know but you
just missed him oh no I I know some of
the other
Kennedys who were there um but not well
but not well right just by how many were
they up there
I think Rory and then another kid uh I
feel embarrassed I don't know his name
he was in my acting class I remember
because we had to go around in the
circle and say your name and a fact that
somebody might remember you by you know
like Lisa Loeb like earlobe and you know
there was somebody Jefferson like
President Jefferson and then went to
Kennedy and then he said somebody
whatever his name was Kennedy and he's
like and somebody's like oh like the
president he's like yeah actually it is
like the president like it was from the
Kennedy family so we both it was great
it was such a it was such a I was just
thinking about it earlier because often
you know you get these name-brand
schools and just because you go to a
name-brand school doesn't necessarily
mean you're getting a great education or
you're gonna be better off than anybody
else you know if you work hard and
things you're passionate about you don't
even need to go to college it really
doesn't matter but I will say at Brown
the students were really interesting
really driven kind of laid-back but
super driven at the same time you know
and I just met so many incredible people
from all over the world and all over the
country a lot of them I'm still friends
with now but just people who kind of
were already doing their life you know
like and like a football player he likes
to do poetry and like a you know just a
lot of people allow the Venn diagrams
were overlapping there were so many
different people with so many different
interests and so driven and and
interesting and smart I really loved it
I should have focused more on studying
what was your major my major was complet
and Spanish Lit so but at this time you
thinking I'm Ibiza I'm like I'm just I
know I'm like I need I was like weakens
believe this is my life like what am i
doing
bringing tortillas from Texas even
though you're from Texas yeah yeah yeah
and I know I I I in retrospect I wish I
had studied something different probably
but I was mostly focused on acting and
doing plays and writing music and
recording music and playing gigs and
towards the end of college we were
driving into New York City to play and
you know it was just but we had such a
great it was the perfect place to play
music too because there were so many
musicians there who took it very
seriously and we were able to take
classes in the recording studio so we
could record our music we had classes
where we would critique each other's
music and what we were doing so we felt
like we better we better be really good
because other musicians that we respect
are also doing this and at the same time
there were there was a great fan base
the students were huge fans from the
minute we started every gig we played it
was packed this is you and your partner
me and my friend Liz yeah she is she's
actually a very successful children's
music artist and she goes by Elizabeth
Mitchell the Smithsonian puts out her
records and she and she and her husband
also have an indie band called Ida
that's very popular on the like real
indie music scene and she I actually
turned to her when it came time for me
to make a record Barnes & Noble came to
me
like about 15 6 17 years ago and asked
if I would make a different kind of
record than my regular records they
wanted to put out a record exclusively
through Barnes & Noble and the record
industry was really starting to change
you know
hmm it was the beginnings of people
really not buying as many records or
just people trying to figure out where
to put records so people would buy them
but the meant Starbucks put them at
Target like where could you put them
where people would actually pay
attention to them and buy them so Barnes
and Noble was a really interesting
partner for me and they asked if I would
make something different for my grown-up
record that they could sell in their
stores and we decided a children's
record would be a good idea did you have
children at the time I had no children I
didn't care about children couldn't care
I don't know about children you know but
I will say I'd always wanted to make a
kid's record or something like that
because I had such nostalgia about
growing up in the 70s and their early
eighties
I loved my childhood I loved the old
Sesame Street's and the old electric
companies and the old Love Boat and Cher
Sonny and Cher show and all those
variety shows in Carol Burnett Donny
Osmond Fernwood tonight I have a crush
on aunt 13 he was messin up my game he
was and you know now Richard Gere I was
in the killing boots
Richard Gere came out with the officer
who stabbed him three times he took his
pants off the gentleman I one of those
double double date this is hilarious
double date and my buddy was having a
hard time with this girl he was dating
and Richard Gere drops his pants in the
beginning of walks with my shirt off and
he hangs on reversion bars everything
but when his ass came out like my I
couldn't believe it the girl's jaw
dropped and the other girl covered her
eyes I was like choking I'm like why are
you covering your eyes was Richard Gere
but this Carol would always talk about
Richard Gere so for years I was in the
stab Richard Gere what thought I was the
kiss it was the car but at that time
already his hair was kind of white no
yeah I can't stand the gentleman I fell
in love with him no he's so great I know
I actually learned about him more later
and I couldn't stop watching movies by
him he's so there's something so sweet
about him and serious pretty woman yeah
I didn't see that when it came out I
will he still well they did it perfectly
whoever his agent was was a [ __ ]
genius right
first they released that movie was just
a piece of [ __ ] cop bags everybody's
wife he takes Andy Garcia and he steals
his wife's I'm doing then put some Randy
Garcia's face oh yeah how's your wife
taste I mean he's she's horrible and
then like you left hanging with Jesus
Richard I'm done with you the two weeks
later he came back a pretty woman it was
all oh oh yeah internal affair internal
affair yeah yeah he's nasty an internal
affairs but he came back he's so great
and then forget I've always loved this
is back to you though I wonder whose
question I thought when I first met you
you said hours okay the walk oh my god
I've been pissed too many Jewish people
in a friend of mine from Boulder I went
to schools Boulder oh wow at UC Boulder
and you see Bolton I had a kid Danny
Weinberger and he kept me out and he
would have a dream of opening a Jewish
[ __ ] Nellie ice cream and he kept
saying I found this spot there's no Jews
would that was I was dead I was just 22
I just seen you know taxes that this
place is after night they stab you open
up Weinberger's had it for like 15 years
cash did so so hungry he moved to serve
island that's all she's not that kinda
schmeckle Dallas there time to do some
text my dad was on the radio there and
they a taco place made up matzo ball
taco for months a joke after um no one
ate it cuz it's disgusting yeah there's
like thousands and thousand T Jews in
Dallas that's amazing that's funny when
I travel around the country actually I
got really into Judaism and when I
traveled around the country I would
visit synagogues and stuff like I
visited a synagogue in in Alaska Wow
during it was um it was a
my brain you know it's um oh my god I
can't believe I can't even think of a
holiday this is terrible
talk about mom what did you do for the
holiday you know you sit out in that and
that shed out the back oh this Sukkot oh
my god I can't believe I just blanked on
it it was Sukkot and what it's the full
moon it's a harvest festival and so
there's a full moon and so up in Alaska
with his Sukkot with us but this little
soka this little Hut and I went there
and I met all these what's great too
about visiting different synagogues is
you just meet nice like regular people
in all these different cities you know
you're not at a club you're not at a
radio station no offense to radio
stations that they're great too but you
know especially there's just a nice
group of people like a regular group of
people I just went to a synagogue and
Seattle it wasn't Seattle it's an island
off of Seattle where I played Robert
Bremerton they had a really nice little
synagogue really nice people they had
meet the rabbi played a guitar he was
like why don't you come up and play a
song I was like I'm just I'm just here
for service I played a Hanukkah song I
have a Hanukkah song it's like a Simon
and Garfunkel sounding song who you
early influences Bowie I love David
Bowie oh [ __ ] I left hunky dory Ziggy
Stardust
Houston I bought those albums so many
times on vinyl cassette tape 8-track
8-track no I died the CDs from the RCA
days before he switched to Reiko I'm
obsessed with David Bowie David Bowie
the police all of it outlandos regarded
a Blanc Zenyatta Madonna
goes to the Machine synchronicity Hey I
cannot believe you know the famous
synchronicity I love a I like it now I
was so disappointed in that when it came
out what wrapped it was very mad your
finger it signals the city this got like
two or three jets I think the best time
was the one by walking out of the moon
that's a great song that in my heart
when you said it oh my god the way the
opening tonight but baby the opening
tonight jammed all right listen I don't
I do dick about the police okay did you
like him in when I was 15 I was good
friends with a gay cop being like that
with this
so he was a guy like me and he was games
for my mother that I was very impressed
with him because he was a seamstress one
for plays like big plays like he was I
have that display for a year I could
last you Maria
I knew he sold drugs what drug I didn't
really know he acted kind of weird but
he would come back every night and tell
me about the clash oh yeah let me go
back to his house and I'd be like
creeped out play the clash for me then
the first police out came oh yeah and I
go get tremendous illegals I'll take you
one day we got a fake ID 78 oh my god
yes remember the Jersey IDs and have you
picture on oh yeah I had a good fake one
from Dallas from Texas somebody made me
and I in Boulder Boulder is where they
took it because they're so good at
checking fake IDs but little dogies
I was in I was in Boulder visiting my
ex-boyfriend who had gone to brown hated
brown went to semester at sea went to
this place that place went to Boulder
where a bunch of his friends were and we
went out and they took my ID I used to
buy beer in college I look like 12 years
old you can I'd walk in with my smiley
face person my hair and pick douche
boots you can buy the beer for the whole
freshman Hall they would suspect you I
was gonna see your cousin yeah I was
like I am the twelve-year-old buying so
you can you graduate Brad and you're
like [ __ ] it ain't going back to Dallas
no well I already felt like I was one in
New York City when I was one of those
people that when I first visited New
York City in eighth grade I was I felt
like those the cartoon of the people who
put their suitcases down on the steps
and you're like New York your mic got it
down you know just felt like home it
felt so exciting an electric I lived
there summer before college I studied
acting and I went there and then I just
I just loved it and my friend Liz her
family was basically from New York City
or New York area that I was singing with
we had a sort of a manager friend he was
helping us with our music by the end of
college we were going to play gigs
already in New York City when we were in
college and it just felt like the
natural progression
I mean Dallas was so conservative when I
grew up it was in the 80s and it was the
Reagan era and it was
you know it was just so conservative
people give you the little up and down
look like your crazy pants Addison was
uptight at me till 2005 yeah I've been
going out as this is 97 after 10 minutes
they just wouldn't take the ride oh yeah
Club all alike me so they kept bringing
me back but I never felt like I met my
made waves in Dallas until I learned how
to play them and I have learned by 2005
I got licked that Dallas room I thought
I was gonna go back pay for it to do a
theater and that a cancel because it's a
movie but I was gonna go to San Antonio
Dallas I cut my comedy it's interesting
to write to go from city to city to like
feel the audiences I talk a lot during
my shows and I heard you talking about
this with someone else on the radio it's
funny on my writer I have I need a local
newspaper because I need to know what
I'm walking into
and I want to know if something happened
that day that that was like a really big
deal so you know it's just in Iowa for a
family thing but you read about like a
tractor thing or like a you don't want
to mention certain things if certain
things are going on in town or you do
want to mention certain things but yeah
it feels so different and it's hard
sometimes also hometowns but New York is
such great over time so well when you
watch this rolling stop Ohio railway
they go from Peru to Brazil to over why
to Colombia and they and they show what
they do would they get that are there
like hundreds of thousands of people to
in the audience right there the chase is
about the airport down the street you
get those books you like you can how
could this happen and then you hit the
drummer going I have a book coming out
what I'm enjoying the band we're lucky
if we got 20 people but my point being
that big Jagger
he said he there's a picked is a three
bit piece of him with papers in his hand
the newspaper just regular paper staple
flip-flops are hairs all jacked up and
still the boys yeah and he was talking
about that when he goes into each city
spoke about this yesterday when he goes
into each city that he reads about
what's going on he's so good he broke
his Spanish done by the
could die elect oh my gosh that's how
good that that's very cold white last
night I go watching this I watched it
two times one day is like a watching
this reminded me how much of a savage
this man really is
I love seeing I love seeing what cuz
he's so casual about it yeah he was
looking he's working his ass off he's
working his ass off I wasn't what they
the whole thing the plot of it is them
goals from city to city with the plan of
ending the tour in Cuba right that was
the plan yeah well he got the cube if he
got those stages I'm CUBAN yeah well he
started talking Cuban my heart stops
like he's he's talking about food it's
very sweet it's very very very that's
also why you do it you know it's fun to
perform it's fun to connect with people
and that's so respectful well a little
tricky but also very respectful well
like I told these guys yes there's a
comic there's nothing worse than going
to Lexington Kentucky
yeah Portland Oregon Kansas City
Missouri and the guy in front is a local
one and he's throwing he he's talking
about the deli in town
oh yeah the local car accident the mayor
got caught getting a job at the cemetery
in Nashville when I was there Terry can
I go right that's the way he got a hand
job they were crazy when you talk about
that time there's a weird connection
that's how you learn but if you really
want to connect say something you know I
love going around the first thing I do
when I go to town is go to a restaurant
a local yeah it does I'm not gonna go to
Morton so I'm definitely gonna done
right that I will go to Whole Foods now
but I will talk about their whole time
like there's a Whole Foods I went to the
other day I don't know where it was
maybe outside of Philly somewhere and
they had
pies that were cut in half like that
just right down the middle they were
selling a half a pie what's the weirdest
thing Lisa if I tell you why they go to
88th Street last week you guys gonna
laugh at me
well I'll tell you the truth I was ready
to shoot up to my all day but just to
walk those steps maybe even walk to my
old grammar school all of 66 just
there's a horse stable there that's the
time-travelling it's a tribe traveling I
was ready to go up there you know what
up there cuz the last time I drove by
there the corner had a [ __ ] hole
boots this used to be let me tell you
what this corner store used to be on
88th Street you're gonna die
the people won't live where were the
kids father from Dark Angel what's that
that's short and see what's that head
showing ABC dark shadows Oh dark shadows
George where's the 88th --an 88th of
Broadway oh yeah yeah so they used to
have a camera store when I was a kid I
went there some days Barnabas Collins
was there without shaking so that's why
I was like how could you replace
Barnabas Collins with a [ __ ]
wholefoods I took my wife for the baby
up you know it's very upsetting
it's very upset I used to live well I
was there only briefly it seemed like a
long time at the time it's probably like
three or four months I lived on Bowery
and bond it's like half a year but it
was when like people were pooping on a
front step it was like the public
restroom was my door you know we lived
above the drug dealers two floors up and
they'd still be having their parties
when I came downstairs to go work at a
hotel but now it's like a really fancy
street everything's super fancy you know
anymore Peter Fogle it was also Kenny
Kenny used to be the Giant yeah yeah
yeah he would get away but I don't I
haven't played there but I like you know
that it's I love playing listening rooms
like the bitter end those places where
you're there and the people are right
there and you're there listening it's
not like a bar bar it's a bar to listen
to listen I love that you probably have
that too because you know when you're
when you're now luckily I'm playing more
theaters and things like that as well or
dinner dinner
places like City Winery where they're
eating and they're watching but it's
really about watching and listening it's
not about being at the bar drinking and
talking how much you travel that I
travel way too much as a mom and way too
little as a musician that's what I feel
like I travel about I probably do like
30 dates a year but I this is the thing
though
I love it I love I hate leaving my kids
but I feel like I'm getting better at
playing gigs yes and that's what's so
crazy is that I really enjoy it I love
that I love talking to the fans I love
being on
JJ I feel very comfortable now it's just
I don't know it's just such a fun thing
I feel like I'm growing as an artist and
yet I really want to be home with my
family too
I think we need to have like Branson
where people come to us I do but we're I
don't I don't even L did you play out in
LA yeah you probably work out material
so what I do is I do two three day tours
a month two three day tours a month is
it similar to what I do but my it's not
regular that yeah every other week yeah
and then one week out bow down to one
week one month I got under one month one
week maybe in November I do three weeks
oh yeah just cuz I feel you know you
have to something that you have for the
twenty it so well that's it you got to
sit there for three weeks yeah blah blah
blah and then you feel like you're
starting over again what so here's luck
so and then you're up there and you're
like this is fine the good thing about
me is I got the Comedy Store oh yes
you're great always Tuesday Wednesday
and Saturday
well I'm with mercy Monday Wednesday
Fridays date night yeah that's great
date now there's always in the itinerary
we are babysit
I mean if we do two and a half hours
it's a lot we're looking at each other
yeah no I know we are we we need to get
back to day/night we've gotten into the
thing where there's like oh and there's
the school function oh and there's the
other thing that you have to perform at
and then all of a sudden we're out two
nights in a week and it's not even
dating rights that date and I we don't
like to be away from we feel like it's
important to be home for bedtime so it's
but we also don't stay up late because
then you got to wake up early in the
morning so it's this whole I'll buy
spots that have to 8:30 and I do but I
run up the hill because that's great
helps is it 6:15 I got you know what
happened Mickey Mouse Club playing god
damn well time to wake up so it's
Groundhog Day so when you went to New
York now what were you thinking in the
early nineties I mean you were just
meeting people planes gonna happen rope
not really my parents were helping me
I was working but I was also I was I was
thinking you know what you already
thought it was a couple years after
college I was working in different
little jobs you know like the Pottery
Barn type it wasn't Pottery Barn UPS
called hold everything it was in Chelsea
I've sold hangers to Willie the bass
player he always gives me a hard time
about that um padded hangers they're
probably scented padded hangers actually
but um I worked there I worked at a
hotel doing room service
other stuff working the breakfast-room I
did a lot of temp work in offices and at
a certain point a couple years in after
college my dad was like you know you
should think about going back to school
and I realized you know what he's right
because if I'm not a musician I would
like to do something else that's really
satisfying to me that's not working at a
hotel or you know working someone else's
store or temp working I would like to
use my mind and use my you know use my
whole self to do a different job so I
went back to school at NYU for
psychology for a master's degree but I
only went for a year and it was very
part-time II it was like two classes at
a time and then once I was there I was
like you know what I'd rather be just a
hundred percent focused on music and
then if that doesn't work out then I'll
go back to school 100% and then within
the year I got a song in a soundtrack
and and everything because I always felt
like I was taking one step forward you
know like more people are at the shows
we were we were always I had a different
friends in the music business who would
give me advice and we were always
collecting information and names for a
mailing list and I would hand write you
know you a hundred cards
I had a friend and at a certain point it
was getting too much with work and music
and my friend who was in the music
business said you need it like an
assistant you need someone who can work
with you and out of the blue my friend
who was working at Ethan's Theatre
Company said hey if you ever need any
extra help let me know so she would help
me make flyers and we would address the
flyers and Xerox copy at the temp work
office and use their phones and actually
be wake away too early in the morning
but just like always doing the next
thing that you do in your professional
musician playing shows playing in Philly
playing in Boston and then all of a
sudden boom having it big hit on the
radio
you're a static you're happy yeah and
also stressed and that's that's crazy
and everybody wants something from you
and everybody thinks you've changed I'm
like I'm still the same exact person I
haven't changed I'm just busy making my
album right now in the studio because
the one song came out but I need to make
the whole record
we signed a record deal when the song
was number one on the charts I signed a
record deal with Geffen Records and I
and my attorney was great and I still
have the same attorney today that I did
back then but just you know just I was a
working professional musician I was it
was so exciting us on TV and learning at
what that's about and you know making
videos and making music and playing with
my band
and getting all of our I also was a very
big fan of getting all of our contracts
getting all of the ducks in a row with
the band members with the producers with
the whatever I wanted everything to be
you know done properly and making
records and writing songs and just on
and on and on
did you go on tour after that I did I
was on national tours I I don't know if
I ever did a lot of t-shirt tours you
know where it's like the t-shirt with
like 30 dates on it you know I felt like
we would do runs of shows like and once
I got signed there was a whole thing
where you would write finish finish
writing the record record the record do
the artwork and all that stuff then
there'd be three months and during those
three months you would go to Europe and
promote the record you go to Japan for a
couple weeks and promote the record come
back to the US promote the record and
then actually the record would come out
then you go back to Europe for two weeks
and two hour or two or three weeks and
Tori I'm back to Japan for two weeks to
tour them back to the US to tour you
know just like the whole thing and then
you would start over again making more
music and it was like this kind of
routine now it's not like that at all
now it's like always recording always
writing always touring like you and I
are talking about where it's like three
days here two days there a week there
bringing the family okay I could be out
for two weeks now you know just this
whole who's paying the most that's a
good place to go where do I want to go
which places where I want to develop my
fanbase further you know just this
constant juggle of going out and playing
that's a good I like it oh yeah listen
I'm watching this the first night but I
couldn't sleep I'm frustrated I got
insomnia I said I did three bong hits
site I dread good see I ate cheeses and
my company visits then I'm gonna have to
a Girl Scout cookies then I'm gonna
change my palette with a little bit of
potato chips I'm gonna just cleanse my
palate with just one spoonful of peanut
butter cuz I need some protein then just
one little chocolate chip well just a
little more than Apple oh that's
I open it with an apple banana if I'm
still hungry then we're gonna have a
problem
it's after 11:00 but if I if it's two of
them where I don't try to eat me they're
nothing so I'll just keep it to like an
apple or banana
but I'm watching this Rolling Stone
thing before we need Cuba there in Cuba
which is a free culture by the way it's
a free country that's it what's Cuba but
that's amazing it whoops where do they
do it in some big like the Atlantis
Sports Center read which is to us is
that field down the corner right there's
a free laughs yeah your Hollywood Park
is 20 times better than that field over
there so but they've got all the old
cars
yeah they had all the old cars and stuff
but they are watching Mick Jagger 73 at
the time right dancing like though shall
we
why don't [ __ ] would you go out at 73 to
do a European tour when you've got
Williams right there kid they can't even
count out which way they're right he's
like in yeah because it's we love what
the [ __ ] we do right now today if you
come to me and say where you going this
weekend go to Pittsburgh
I love Pittsburgh yeah it's funny I want
to go not really
so from now till tomorrow at 11 o'clock
I'll be a little [ __ ] Lisa I'm not
gonna be alive I'll be a little [ __ ]
I'm looking for excuses I got a toenail
once I slammed the door that oh but yo
you're there it's like you're already
there I get the hell ax I got both clear
then look at your eyeballs yeah you go
through okay you're already there do
that that's right there you're there
tomorrow I take collecting flight there
what there is the exacting flight you're
there
what you get to the hotel you take your
iPad on you like your sleep apnea
machine
why did you picture your wife I think
Eddie bad she gave me the way yeah a
little bit again that's it you're there
you're home yeah you know it's like the
Mick Jagger said he goes I used to hide
Mike's my management wanted me to hide
what taught to hide you know what we
gonna what tab he knows it's [ __ ]
part of the gig shaking hands giving
autographs talking to people that's part
of it I just accepted it I love it I
love you telling you tonight yeah what
everybody goes to sleep tonight take you
a little glass of wine whatever better
chef it's you guys
crackers and she likes gee I'm just like
in my cheese it's basically GI like
Jesus they're like a pastry I love
history of watching I love cheese but I
get to stone sometimes I like to cheese
it with the peanut butter but in a while
I'm such a gavone I just put the peanuts
he's it'll be the product and the peanut
butter that's awesome you you're just I
wanted you to come on the show Lisa yeah
you know yeah you know to talk a little
bit but I really have a lot of respect
for you you're amazing in a lot of ways
because that laser money talks and
[ __ ] walk type of place you you walk
the walk I mean you don't stop you're a
mom but most people don't understand is
that once you become a parent you unless
you want your kid to be you know like
out there right you have to put love and
time into that child I don't want my
daughter you don't want your children
not to know who the hell you are yeah
you're making a ton of money you know
you watch the dirt yet and I haven't
[ __ ] two years on the road oh my god
Led Zeppelin did that I know I know
cellphones
imagine they probably figure out their
lives at home and you had to go to
Western Union write a [ __ ] no but no
what do you want to write on the No
Oh Joey loves me big deal yeah you know
I mean two years
yeah I've been went in at or eight weeks
one time for like cable oh my gosh and
it was too much yeah no I won't do more
than a week I do a week I did the
Carlisle in New York which was two weeks
but I knew that my in-laws who have been
great also they help with the kids
especially if it's like a little longer
to her than I would like to be on though
they come and they help out and so they
were in Los Angeles when I was at the
first week at the Carlisle and the
second week the Carlile gave me an extra
room and a room for the kids and
everybody just came for the week and so
it was I could do that I actually that's
one of my dreams is to do tours during
the summer
where
like a three-week tour a four-week tour
I could get most of the gigs out of the
way for the year have the kids with me
with another grown-up whether it's my
husband and in-law a good friend
in addition to my tour manager is my son
engineer and just like do the thing we
used to do we drive around the country
when I was a kid and we'd stop in Santa
Fe and you know I could just play my
show at night at 7:30 8 o'clock hour and
a half sign autographs be done by 11:00
go sleep somebody takes the kids to
breakfast and then we go do something
for a little bit or we take a little
Drive it'd be great on the east coast
where the cities are closer together but
just sort of combine the like United
States trip with the touring because I'm
not doing a ton of morning radio anymore
right now or the left so it's like it
makes it it it makes more free time and
I'm really you know I could do a sound
check but I could do that pretty quickly
or like even Europe like go to France I
haven't really been outside of much
other than like Paris or Versailles like
go someplace where there's a whole
country that you forget and have a car
and go and stay in like a
bed-and-breakfast and play some weird
little 150 seat venue little Club and
then play in France or what you know
play in Paris but take the family I
don't know if it's realistic with jet
lag but it's one of my dreams to be able
to see the country see the world do my
work because because that's the other
thing I don't know if you do this but
you have to be so able to change gear so
quickly you literally can be honest and
go I'm like you feel like a superstar
doing your thing playing your music two
seconds later be an artist writing you
know being this other head where you're
writing ready and then be in this other
head where you're picking rice up off
the floor and it's totally you're where
you are sort of when you're there it's
as I became a comedian I didn't take my
work around the comedy seriously I wrote
but when I went on the road it was more
to be destructing like Motley Crue oh
yeah after I became a headliner and I
started thinking about the people coming
to my show I got I got a babysitter they
gonna drive is a paper ticket they only
go to dinner i I changed everything I do
you know some nights sometimes I fly
into that early just to get dinner at
that town get the feed right go back
watch that flick still 2:00 or 3:00 in
the morning you're under these you know
you're on West but you don't need to get
up
but even take that seriously like don't
feel like you have to wake up an
annoying makes you watch your sleep yes
be where you are but what about that
like your your comedy I know when I did
the Carlisle it was a big turning point
for me was a couple years ago like I
said I like to talk a lot on stage
sometimes it'll be half talking half
music and there I like in my mind I
think I every show has to be totally
different totally different has to be to
be with what you're saying even what is
what I'm saying it'll be different
everything has to be different it can't
be the same and now especially with
social media I'm like everything has to
be different but I've toured with like I
toured with Lyle Lovett for one of those
long tours before and I watched him and
he he knew what he was gonna say every
night and it worked every night in these
huge theaters and it was great it was
kind of like a play it wasn't a play
he's really playing and whatever he said
came from his heart but he would say the
same things and I had a whole new
respect for it I was like that works
what he's doing works and that is an art
to be able to get up there and then I
was hanging out with some comedians for
a while and I saw them working on things
and started realizing people were
repeating material you can't do new
stuff all the time you have to sort of
hone in on certain things and then be
able to mess around but with the carlyle
to me that was this very special upscale
think people are paying over $100 to see
me play there right in front of me it's
this tiny little place it to me it had a
lot of cachet we're like classic people
sing and tell stories and they do
cabaret and I need to tighten up my act
so it's not so all over the place with
trying to be so different every time and
I'm trying to find that balance between
saying the same things and working on
certain stories that are fun to tell
where people always react a certain way
and and coming up with new different
stuff but how do you do that like do you
do you go through phases of similar
material or like how does that work I
like to mix it up okay I never do the
same set twice I love mixing it up the
aura so tonight I opened up with snow
and clothes would stay yeah yeah
Wednesday I open up what could stay and
take my chances right right I open up
[ __ ] it's strong right out the [ __ ]
box right I talked him down a little bit
I don't want a musician speaking I but I
went to see Santana a couple of years
ago I almost put a gun in my [ __ ]
watch that to replace what
they're [ __ ] talking about oh we're at
a great place now you got to bring up
injustice to Mexicans now after I did
you know 22 joints now I feel [ __ ]
guilty to come to a shell come on oh you
know this is uh this is a song this is
the other problem I have when you're a
musician if I pay for Lisa Loeb she'd
better [ __ ] place today oh yes I will
collect a guitar ukulele latest song
that you know the song that I know a
couple songs that yeah you have to play
all the songs you know when you're a
comic you some comics like well they
came to hear that particular joke right
right I don't really feel that way but I
do sometimes right sometimes I do if
it's a joke that made me as something I
do but I don't really want to say it
where music if I pay 800 to see the
[ __ ] stones a better place to see the
devil yeah exactly I want to see that
that one I want to see it's only rock
roll so that's the problem I have it's
funny early on I I remember when stay
was really really popular the song stay
and my drummer who's no longer my
drummer but were friends for friends
we've talked about it but it was so
funny cuz he was such a pain in the ass
he's like well we're not gonna play stay
right we played at CBGB's and it was a
big deal that we were playing this
little club and we're not gonna play
stay I'm like are you kidding me people
drove in from New Jersey like they drove
in to hear that one song that's all they
want to hear and it was written from all
from the same place as all the other
songs I wasn't trying to like sell out
or you know I was just writing another
song and that one became popular they
are gonna get what they want to hear
they better like when I go see Hall &
Oates
they better play all their songs you
know Sarah smart I gotta see Sarah smile
sometimes they save up all that stuff
Julianne and I'm really sensitive to and
maybe I shouldn't be so sensitive but I
have always all these new songs and a
lot of people know my first two records
the best and they're from 20 years ago
or twenty five years ago but I've got
like multiple multiple songs and records
since then and I want to sprinkle them
through the set and make sure they hear
things that I want to share as well do
you switch your set you know your ass do
you know but I do find that there are
certain songs that I like opening with
because I know that that if the
equipment is bad or something
going wrong I could sing if I couldn't
even hear myself I could sing these
songs standing on my head I feel
comfortable I know what it feels like
I like playing an upbeat song when I
come out sometimes I change it up but
there's a couple songs I like playing
and that's the other thing sometimes in
my head I'm playing such different sets
but then I go out there I'm like I
always play these songs because it works
well or like I like to play this kind of
song and then play a couple songs from
this other album that they don't really
know and then play something they really
know and then you know tell a story
about something else like it just has an
ebb and flow but I did years ago start
having an am request section whether I'm
playing for kids or for grown-ups I have
two different types of sets that I do
there's a I placed a and then I'll maybe
play another song of my choice that I
want them to listen to because just
because I played something that they
really wanted to hear then I can play
something they might not know as well
right after it and then it's requests
people can ask for whatever they want
like three four or five songs i watched
the live stream from austin you're very
good at live streaming and stuff and
yeah a couple months ago I was at home
bleep you know you know live stream I
think it was on Twitter or Facebook oh
yeah maybe they streamed it and they
said writing watching you oh my god that
way it was raining probably no real
quick oh she's not [ __ ] around out
there and you were a smiling you were
having a great time and not to harp on
it
that movie with the stones again every
night they opened up with a different
[ __ ] song see that's cool too
one night they opened up with out of
control which whoa whoa and I was like
what [ __ ] but again and during that
movie there was one part where he's in
Cuba he's singing I can't get no
satisfaction and Cubans estab themselves
you know and I'm sitting there thinking
probably [ __ ] times based on this one
right and it still so they chase it up
they make it bluesy they they just know
that yeah yeah I know when I was a kid
I'd go sit I'd go meet musicians they
came to town my friends and I would go
get people's autographs at the record
store and all that stand in line we
would we thought we were a very new wave
we were we were very new wave and fun
and we'd make a pineapple cake if it
look like a pineapple and give
- like flock of seagulls and we were
fans you know we weren't groupies we
were fans but we were also felt like
journalists we would literally like
interview bands and stuff like that and
videotape them but it was filmed because
it was you know that super 8 film
and so I know what it's like to be on
the other side to be a fan who's not
he's not a weird fan they're just a big
fan or if you know somebody I could
actually maybe be friends with you know
like as a fan sometimes you're like no
you don't understand
famous musician we could actually be
friends and yet they're thinking oh the
musician doesn't think we could actually
first but like I do meet fans that I've
become friendly with like you know you
have your boundaries and everything but
like I appreciate it so much like my
parents were big music fans I'm a big
music fan we used to wait to like get
someone on Broadway's autograph after
they did their show like there's
something exciting you want to as the
King say give that people what they want
who are some of the people you met when
you brought the cakes like flock to see
you like I say the alarm yeah I didn't
meet the cars but I love the cars and I
used to not candy I was like sure those
records are so good the one with oh my
god I'm a violent anatomic Records did
not close whoever spread in the room
they did not close I win I haven't been
to Burbank and everybody kept breaking
my heart you come to our house our house
is like a record store my husband
collects so much vinyl it's crazy 100
and I have all my old vinyls still in
Texas I'm actually gonna sell some of it
to a record store in Dallas that I just
I don't know that's a guy in Kansas City
when I went with Dean last year Dean Del
Rey who does a basically music podcast I
know Dean through the drummer of my band
yeah he's a great guy and Dean went to a
place and came back their place in
Kansas City where they get calls like
hey man my father was the drummer for
the Allman Brothers that he died he's
got a trailer full of [ __ ]
if you don't come together I'm gonna
throw it out and he's got like every
tour jacket Wow Michael Jackson which is
probably worth a dollar you know that
makes me upset it's like that Bill Cosby
thing I was such a huge Bill Cosby fan I
have his records he was the guy I
learned how to tell stories from Alice
to his records that watch his videos I
loved him I met him once and Bill Cosby
what did you do it's so somebody told me
there was a comedian who had a or a guy
who I'd like his whole tell Cosby tattoo
on his whole back oops it's very
upsetting on somebody who name their kid
Cosby let that happen Bill Cosby
he's a comedian so take that one so
disappointing disappointed I was I was a
little bit of a Cosby fan I was his
storytelling buddy Bruce typing oh yeah
of course but then I did a festival and
he was the star of the festival then
when I walked in I was maybe 10 feet
from him and I could hear him tell the
festival coordinators how there was no
room for blue material in comedy but he
hates Buch obviously better make sure
there's no blue comics in the festival
and I just turned my back that's like a
yeah that's that's too much
cutting down an artist you ever say away
especially if he's doing what he's doing
on the side there that makes it well
this is the worst thing that nobody
remembers and this is where it will piss
me off in 80 75 Lisa Bonet from the show
for doing angel heart with Mickey Rourke
because she had a sex scene how can you
think that's terrible you got remember
that I remember that and she said [ __ ]
you and she was hooked up with the
bloody Kravitz and the rest is history
yeah but you know here's a girl who did
a sex scene and there was an r-rated
sexy there's an x-rated sexy right
there's two of them for this movie and
he fired her and that's fired 30 years
later 20 years later 30 years later he
gets convicted to the crime that he does
that's the kind of [ __ ] that's not right
each micro Michael Jackson on the other
hand first time I bought when I came
from Cuba was ABC so I don't think
that's I'm [ __ ] of devastated but it
does you see those pictures of him at
the end with the [ __ ] eyeball
sticking up and [ __ ] yeah he was a
meatball he needed people you needed
real people in his life you know this
this this businesswoman to take you for
a ride how did you survive I
friends and family I'm just like a
regular person with a family uncle no
drugs no I'm just I I first of all I
have the same front of I have a lot of
new friends - including your wife like
I've met some really great people
through my kids but I've always had
really close friends I have one of my
best friends our moms were pregnant at
the same time we were born in the same
hospital a month apart another friend I
was just saying and she was in she she
works over the hill she lives a mile
away from me we grew up in Dallas
together we were best friends between
second and third grade like I have all
these friends just all these friends and
family I have two brothers and a sister
who I'm close with my parents they keep
you good they you keep they're just your
normal your like yeah your songs on the
radio can you please go help Mom with
the car you know it's it's just it's a
great support system and I'm also just a
really responsible person I just do it
did you ever know you know I need to buy
into it more I need to buy into it more
because I think like you said at a
certain point you have to take it
seriously I do take it seriously but I
think it's really important for us it's
you know being a creative person and
being an artist and being a performer
it's it's not as trying as being like an
athlete but you definitely have to have
routines and you have to have be able to
take care of yourself as a good you know
like I I had I have had people in my
lifes who have been big stoners or more
drinkers and this and that and it seems
glamorous for a minute but I need to be
awake I need to look awake I need to be
able to think and it just didn't make
sense to me that like oh I need to drink
so that I can perform or oh I need to
take drugs so I can perform or do my job
I'm like that doesn't sound very
sustainable
you know like I'm too factual and I like
so I just I didn't do that and then I'm
just working you know maybe I do need to
unwind a little bit
yeah that's good you go to yoga I don't
do yoga very much you know I do strength
training we're at at somebody's home and
at a personal trainers home first
weights or any weights little machines
they're great if you want to know them
though I do I go to string - yeah I love
string and I've been doing it for 30
years I love that suit I'm sure you are
I love walking I'm like an old person
like I like walking light strength
training and dancing I'm taking dance
class yeah I was a dancer
you know my class company and I really
it's so much really what's to the
website it's called Lisa Loeb eyewear so
it's Lisa Loeb eyewear the parent
company is a company called class seek I
were but you can just look up Lisa Loeb
eyewear and all my eyewear collection is
there its ever-growing and they sell it
at mom-and-pop like your ophthalmologist
up tution office where it has a little
store but it's also at Costco and it's
women's glasses and children's classes
at Costco and you also have children's
books I do have a couple of kids books I
need to write some more books though one
day what did you god what did you have
the kids when you start allowing the
kids but you have the kids with cancer
I have such nostalgia you are talking
about going back to our used to live
going back to your old school I love
that time travel I wanted I wanted to
create stuff that was funny
and you know like back in the 70s there
was all the entertainment that was for
grown-ups but kids would watch it we
watch all in the family whatever right
we would also watch the Waltons in the
Waltons in 222 yeah exactly you know III
don't work Sundays
alright I refuse to work you don't work
send it I do not work Sundays I do
paperwork and other work okay I refuse
to get out of state for Sunday's first
of all it's the Sabbath for me right
number two I grew up on Disney oh yeah
the wonderful wonderful world of Disney
that [ __ ] Lions show afterwards
Daktari Daktari you know I grew up on as
corny as it sounds everybody
I [ __ ] love Lawrence Welk because at
the time oh yeah I was such an immigrant
and I felt like such an outsider that
for me to become an American I had a
loved American things yeah and I would
sit there and do that little [ __ ]
German dance and do like you know he uh
he oh that's Jesus Christ you know so
eat a Tennessee watch and watch I would
watch him you know the dance show oh my
god it was on Sundays I come home from
Sunday School
Sunday opera drama Soul Train American
Bandstand you know so all that stuff
midnight oh yeah I made the midnight
special the midnight my parents my mom
woke us up one night on a Friday night
because the kiss was gonna be on with no
makeup this isn't a 70s that kiss is
gonna be on with no makeup and we were
such huge kiss fans
you know woke up in the middle of the
night my siblings and I to watch The
Midnight Special and then they showed
kiss and they were sitting on a park
bench with their backs to the camera
being interviewed so you couldn't see
them without their makeup I'm trying to
give a freely of you
oh and just like without drugs he's not
funny
well it might be the first I know poor
taste
I read Paul Stanley's biography it was
really great I got David Lee Roth I'm
gonna take on the road oh that's great
read that one oh yeah the one I'm still
trying to finish because it's brilliant
is the man who led Zeppelin Peter Grant
how am I gonna read that any grants
managed by I read when years ago was a
little paperback yeah the guy's a hammer
the guy again I'd the great when his
Patti Smith that's a curse she wrote a
few great books
dude she yeah there are a couple of
Viagra fees I tried to read and I just
couldn't read them that were just not
readable they were not well written sir
I loved the Lenny Bruce book when he
lived in the Chelsea I loved well had
nostalgia also yeah so I wanted to make
well that's how I got into kids music I
wanted to make things like the stuff
they something about camp like summer
camp summer camp album all my old summer
camp songs cuz also when you're a kid
it's not kids music you're a teenager
and you're singing it you think it's
really funny and fun and gross and
sentimental and you love it and so I I
made it kids summer camp song records
with a couple friends and started a
foundation to send kids to summer camp
through the camp Lisa Foundation and we
ended up making a musical and
off-broadway musical that played in New
York City at the Atlantic Theater about
summer camp and that led to doing books
that had the lyrics from some of those
songs plus other songs but um yeah it's
just it's it's fun it's like fun and
serious and you could just do all kinds
of different things making kids music I
like it no you have a thousand that's
that you wear and I love you whatever
you want to come back on your clothes by
just give me a call you were great I
mean this is great yeah such a surprise
to get to meet you anyway I didn't know
you dated weed so it's one of the best
guitar players out there yeah it's a
great guitar very [ __ ] underrated
very well it's great because he's
playing his dad's music is he doing it
he's doing it how they do it does garage
you know that's that I don't know
they're doing Jos cars are doing a lot
of different songs and I think he's
might be worth music actually right now
he's on a Hendrix tour he's out with the
Hendrix with like Joe Satriani and a
bunch other guys yeah
I had Terry Bozzio so oh yeah big
missing-persons Joe's Garage oh yeah
Frank Zappa mazing amazing so I had a
bond hit but I have always said that the
only knock I have against this Dweezil
is he played on Don Johnson's out but
hypnotize yeah yes I would tight they
would tight Dodd grew up
yeah his house and stuff that was tight
he's it's it's interesting all those
folks that you meet like I remember
hanging out in a kitchen at the
madhavi's house watching sports with Don
Johnson very weird I don't know yeah Don
Johnson kicked it around for a while but
anytime you want to come on let me
promote these dates for you okay yeah
coming up this Sunday you're at McCabe's
guitar shop in Santa Monica yes that is
a kids show okay it'll be fun for
everybody it's a 30 in the morning look
at you tickets are almost sold out so
really yes and then the 13th you have to
Hard Rock I am at the Hard Rock
raucous Eno venue in Northfield Ohio
which is near Cleveland it's good for
the March 28th or the 26 year at world
it is like April April April 28 I'm
looking oh I hear wait before that I'm
playing oh but it's sold out I'm playing
in Boston at City Winery sold out April
24th yes World Cafe live in Philly on
April 26th Rams head live in Annapolis
Maryland that's a great venue and I have
to get crab cakes and then yeah the 28th
I'm playing at the Hamilton in
Washington DC
you're beautiful you even got a coffee
line I do have a coffee line probably
got blend now what gives all these
people and my friend a friend of mine
who manages Billy Bob Thornton yeah
connected me to this great coffee
company called coffee fool and it's an
online place to order coffee beans and
he started a thing the people who
started the company started a thing with
a couple of different musicians and
people that they'll let you put together
your own personal coffee blend like mine
is dark roast beans for that really
strong I'm going to be
flavor but also light beans for the
actual caffeine and it's shade-grown and
all that and all the proceeds from the
sale of this wake-up blend that you can
buy online they give all of it to my
camp ELISA foundation so they've sent so
many kids to camp they also have a blend
with I think sticks and with Billy Bob
Thornton and maybe a couple of other
folks know too but it's great it's
coffee fool and you go to their
charities button on their website and
you'll see my coffee there and it's
delicious I'm gonna try it with you
drink coffee yes okay I ask you
something Lisa Loeb this has been an
honor and a pleasure thank you very much
for taking the time you're a sweetheart
if you ever need to come on for any
reason you have an open-door policy you
want to do midnight what if you want to
sing on hear something get the [ __ ]
lights go whatever you need
periscope won't get girls who began
whatever you because it bikinis that's
what I got you yeah thank you very much
thank you so much I appreciate it
thank you I want to thank Lisa Loeb
would come on the podcast again today I
want to thank the [ __ ] for
making it happen and I want to thank you
guys for this is important let me get
with thank to us a little sponsors here
was sponsored by Post Bates your
personal delivery service I mean in this
life who can you count on really who
who's gonna bring you a nice little red
wine at 4:00 in the afternoon who's
gonna bring you a sushi when a good
movies coming out on HBO at nine o'clock
who's gonna bring you a nice breakfast
burrito I'll tell you who posts maids
post mates is your personal delivery
service whatever you want whenever you
want it they'll bring it nobody delivers
like post mates no more annoying trips
to the store you got your little pajamas
on your charm collectors you don't even
have to have to you don't even have to
know where the store is
post mates will deliver anything to you
download the app it's available on
iphone or android
browse to local restaurants and
businesses all from the comfort of your
couch you're the king of the castle Jack
living like a doctor your wish is their
command 24 hours a day 365 days a week
postmates will bring you what you want
within the hour
anything you're craving postman to
deliver they're the largest under man
network in the known universe with more
than 25 thousand stores and rest
what a bit doofy is this for a limited
time the church family's gonna get one
of ours a free delivery credit you hear
what I'm saying to you 100 hours of free
delivery credit with you for your first
7 days free money once you download the
app how's that for you so you hear what
I'm saying it for a little time post
lates is gonna give the church family
100 miles are free delivery for your
first seven days it's free money it's
like stealing
that's post lates to start your free
deliveries download the app right now
and use promo code grab a pen Joey Diaz
jo e y di AZ capitals all across all
right how you call it that's Joey Diaz
for $100 of free delivery credit for
your first 7 days when you download the
post lates app you get anything you need
anytime you need it download post mates
and save with code Joey Diaz Joey why di
AZ go to post mates right now download
the app you're gonna be happy you're
gonna have me back and going Joey that's
why you live like a doctor cuz you got
post lates
you heard that right another sponsor who
I love a door on it calm the best
supplements are B goes all over the
world looking for supplements have you
ever had that chocolate shakes taste
that chocolate that's real cocoa
whatever the hell they call it cacao
Goku I don't know what the [ __ ] it is
whether it's the shroom tech the alpha
brain with a 30 day money back guarantee
and it was the product back how good is
that who does that for you nobody so go
to islet dot-com right now and press in
church and get 10% off your first order
delivered right to the crib kettlebells
weighted vest bats I can't do this via
there but with the supplements uncle
Joey got you 10% off delivered to your
house press Church CH you are ch4 you
dummies out there and get 10% to live at
the house you're gonna feel better your
minds gonna think better gonna be more
clear
I want to thank post mates I want to
thank on it but most importantly I want
to thank you guys don't forget April
20th oh [ __ ] the paps Peter the first
one sold out and the second ones halfway
there and you're 10 days
a reefer McGillicutty pills whatever the
[ __ ] you need is gonna be going down a
bill walking that night so let a papist
either right now and get your
[ __ ] tickets cuz we're going
deep my Bey dates are getting
rescheduled cuz of a film and I'll keep
your [ __ ] posted without that I
love you guys have a great weekend
get ready to rock and I'll see you
[ __ ] Monday tip top
[ __ ] but GU Lee kick this bill
a little Lisa Loeb on the way up
stay black I love you people